thank you very much it's my great honor
to have the very popular and by the way
great athlete one of the greatest but
very popular Prime Minister of Pakistan
we have many things to discuss military
and terrorism and trade and I think
we're going to spend a lot of time
talking about trade because we do very
little trade with Pakistan compared to
what we could be doing and should be
doing what I thought you really get
along perfectly and I think we're having
that start we're going to have that
start but there's tremendous upside with
respect to trade one of the things we're
going to be discussing too is hostages
perhaps the polio vaccine because
Pakistan is one of the countries and
we'll talk about that has to you know
what your feeling is on that but we have
a situation in Pakistan where we want to
talk about the polio or the possible
polio vaccine and I think we can have
great meetings we're going to be
spending a long time together we have
our representatives meeting right after
we're finished and we just came out mr.
prime minister with tremendous economic
numbers for the United States the best
we've ever had we got the best economy
we've ever had and I think we can ship
some of that over to Pakistan we should
be doing tremendous business together so
to the UN that's a big question I keep
going for hours I will say that we have
a very good relationship with India I
know that your relationship is strained
a little bit maybe a lot but we will be
talking about India there a big part of
our conversation today and I think maybe
if we can help in to see do whatever we
have to do but I think it's something
that can be brought back together and
we'll also be talking about Afghanistan
we've reduced that number of troops
there by quite a bit we are continuing
to reduce troops in Afghanistan while
working with Pakistan and others on
getting an agreement signed as you know
and we'll see what happens but we will
be talking about in
and Afghanistan very much I know all
about it I know all about
Huawei I know all about the 5g and they
were working on it and we have companies
that are now getting very very strong in
that department we're gonna have 5g
we're gonna have the best 5g in the
world just like we have everything else
are silicon silicon vally cannot be
competed with there's nobody that can
compete with Silicon Valley for the
brain power or for what we do and nobody
was focused on 5g but now they are and
we have great companies going into 5g
even if they don't want it to have a lot
of them were very happy doing what they
were doing but now they're going at my
request they're going into 5g so we
don't need we don't need anything from
our relationship with North Korea's been
very good we've really established a
good relationship with kim jeong-hoon
I have personally there's no rocket
testing there's no missile testing we're
getting our remains back we got our
hostages back and we have a very very
good relationship the two of us and
that's very important there's been no
nuclear testing and what they're doing
with 5g will be
well I think we're gonna have a great
meeting today I know it's an important
meeting I consider this a very important
meeting because I think we haven't met
the potential of either country I think
the potential with Pakistan and and
likewise the opposite way I think we
have not even come close to meeting it
there is tremendous potential between
our country and Pakistan I think
Pakistan's going to help us out to
extricate ourselves we're like policemen
we're not fighting a war we wanted to
fight a war in Afghanistan and win it I
could win that war in a week
I just don't want to kill 10 million
people does that make sense to you I
don't want to kill 10 million people
I have plans on Afghanistan that if I
wanted to win that war Afghanistan would
be wiped off the face of the earth it
would be Ghana it would be over in
literally in ten days and I don't want
to do that I don't want to go that route
so we're working with Pakistan and
others to extricate ourselves nor do we
want to be policemen because basically
what policemen right now and we're not
supposed to be policemen we've been
there we've been there for 19 years in
Afghanistan it's ridiculous and I think
Pakistan helps us with that because we
don't want to stay as policemen but if
we wanted to we could win that war I
have a plan that would win that war in a
very short period of time you understand
that better than anybody we've been in
there not fighting to win just fighting
- they're building
gas stations they're rebuilding schools
the United States we shouldn't be doing
that that's for them to do but what we
did and what our leadership got us into
is ridiculous but we will I think we'll
have some very good answers on
Afghanistan very quick
we are going to this we were saying 1.3
billion to Pakistan is a working for
many years the problem was Pakistan this
is before you Pakistan was not doing
anything for us they were really I think
subversive they were going against us
and this is something will be tie ended
that about a year and a half ago the 1.3
billion dollars and I tell you what to
be honest I think we have a better
relationship with Pakistan right now
than we did when we were paying that
money but all of that can come back
depending on what we work out we're
working out things that are very
important we have avert this I consider
this very important we're working out
things that are very very important and
I think at the end of this at the end of
a very short time we're gonna have a
very great relationship with Pakistan
and we should it's a great country it's
a great they're great people I have many
friends from Pakistan living in New York
I have a lot of Pakistani friends I will
tell you that and they're great people
smart tough they are tough there's no
question about that
no I'm not going to be watching probably
maybe you'll see a little bit of it I'm
not gonna be what watching Muller
because you can't think all those bytes
out of the Apple
we had no collusion no obstruction we
had no nothing we had a total no
collusion finding the Democrats were
devastated by it they went crazy they've
gone off the deep end they're not doing
anything they're not doing health care
they're not doing infrastructure they're
not lowering drug prices I'm lowering
drug prices first time in 53 years that
drug prices went down with 53 years and
I'm doing that without the help of
Congress which makes it much tougher to
do because if they work with us I could
get drug prices down and half but the
Democrats don't seem to care about drug
prices all they care about is a phony
investigation where the report was
written it said no collusion the report
was written and the Attorney General
based on the report was easily able to
find there was no obstruction there's no
nothing they're wasting their time and
Robert Muller I know he's conflicted he
had a lot there's a lot of conflicts
that he's got including the fact that
his best friend is combing but he's got
conflicts with me too
he's got big conflicts with me as you
know he wanted the job of the FBI
director he didn't get it and we had a
business relationship where I said no
and I would say that he wasn't happy
that all of a sudden he gets this
position but you know what he's still
ruled and I respect him for it he still
ruled no coloration no obstruction and
this thing should have ended a long time
ago this has been going on for two and a
half years and we're never going to
allow this to happen to another
president again because most stuff would
be able to take it on top of everything
else we have the strongest economy we
were just discussing this with the prime
minister we have the strongest economy
that the United States has ever had we
have the highest stock market yesterday
literally the highest stock market we've
ever had on Friday Thursday we've broken
the record I think 109 times our highest
stock market but on I believe Thursday
of last week we hit the all-time highest
and the his
our country our country is doing
phenomenally well unemployment is the
lowest in 51 years soon to be the lowest
in history if it keeps going this way in
a short period of time black Hispanic
Asian unemployment the lowest in history
women the lowest in 72 years nobody has
ever done what we've done nobody's done
in two and a half years what we've done
the biggest tax cuts in history the
biggest regulation cuts in history so
many things for health care we got rid
of the individual mandate which was the
worst part of Obamacare when it could
end up if we end up winning the house
back we keep the presidency we should
keep the Senate we should keep the
presidency I would think easy when you
have the strongest economy in the
history of our country and somebody's
gonna run against that particular
president even though in this case it's
me so a lot of great things are
happening but the Democrats they don't
want to talk about that they want to
stay off the economy subject and what
they're doing is just hearing after
hearing after hearing it's nonsense
okay they tried an impeachment vote and
they got slaughtered last week they got
absolutely slaughtered it was a most
ridiculous I didn't even know we know
they were going to do it and I'll tell
you just in finishing I have a lot of
respect for the Democrats because most
most of them voted against impeachment
last week and I have a lot of respect
for those Democrats that did that
because they're doing the right thing
for the country no collusion no
obstruction okay yeah we're talking
about it
secretary minuchin is talking about
having very good talks with the Speaker
of the House with Nancy Pelosi we're
having very good talks with Chuck
Schumer and of course with Mitch
McConnell and Kevin
we are Kevin McCarthy we are I think
doing very well on debt if you look at
that limit however you want to define
that but we're doing very well on that
and I think we're doing pretty well on a
budget very important that we take care
of our military our military was
depleted and in the last two-and-a-half
years
we've under pleaded it okay to put it
Bob Lee we have made it stronger than
ever before we need another big year so
we had 700 billion we had then 716
billion and this year we're going to be
asking for a number slightly larger than
that we're putting our military back
into a shape that it's never been in
before new the best missiles in the
world the best equipment in the world
the best military equipment of what
we're building submarines the finest
nobody can even think about competing
with what we're building we're building
as you know new submarines we have a new
aircraft carrier coming online so
largest ship in the world it's so large
that maybe I could even learn to plan on
top of it okay then it's a big it's a
big one President Gerald Ford it's a
phenomenal it's a phenomenal ship so
what we're doing what we're doing is
incredible things for our country and I
might say this about the military
equipment it's all made in the USA
everything 100% it's all made in the USA
and you know it's one of the reasons our
job numbers probably is so good lowest
unemployment yeah Pakistan is a great
country so he will be definitely
extending your invitation
so Pakistan well I can't say that yeah
because so far he has not extended and
after today's meeting maybe you want but
I have a feeling he might guess I'd love
to go to
[Music]
are you talking about from Afghanistan
yeah yeah we have already withdrawn
quite a few and we're doing it very
slowly very safely and we're working
with Pakistan and with as you know we're
negotiated with the Taliban and you are
doing I think very well in that regard
again it's something that we can do we
can go one of two ways we could do a
number the likes of which they've never
seen before and win it very quickly I
don't want to do that that's because
we're talking about millions of people
and I don't want to do that and we're
working with Pakistan and getting a
solution and I think I think it's being
[Music]
we've done what we were supposed to do
we've been there for 19 years and we've
acted as policemen not soldiers and
again if we wanted to be soldiers it
would be over in ten days one week to
ten days if we wanted to but I have not
chosen that wife why are we why would we
kill millions of people it wouldn't be
fair in terms of humanity it wouldn't be
fair so we're doing very well and I
think that Pakistan is going to be a big
you see this is the closest with
says if you go all out military there
will be millions and billions of people
who will die so there is only one
solution to what the Prime Minister just
said is a very big story and it's a
hundred percent to where we've made a
lot of progress over the last couple of
weeks and Pakistan has helped us with
that progress but a lot of great things
are happening a lot of things are
happening for the United States and I
think a lot of great things are going to
be happening for Pakistan too I think
Iran doesn't know where they are
I've been watching and reading a lot of
reports and right now they're a very
mixed up country they don't know whether
they're coming or going
they have tremendous problems
economically their country's in turmoil
they're having demonstrations all over
Iran their inflation rates at 75 percent
they have a lot of problems so whatever
it is it is I'm just gonna sit back and
wait let's see what happens but I will
say they are doing they are doing very
poorly as a country and we'll see what
happens we did actually because they
said no and you know it's a religious
country or religious leaders but they
lie a lot we did shoot down
unfortunately we had to shoot down a
drone the drone came down you know how
it would how it came down with a new
technology that's actually quite amazing
but we took down one of their drones
instead of saying yeah that happened
he'd lied they say it didn't happen so
we have there's a lot of proof it's
called take a look at it in the ocean
floor just go down there take your
scooping here and go down there in the
open what do you would do that I know
but we took down a drone I think very
importantly I read a report
about CIA that's totally a full story
that's another lie they put out
propaganda they put out lies
I don't think Pakistan would ever do a
thing like that Pakistan never lies but
Iran does unfortunately so let's see
what happens with Iran we are ready for
the absolute worst and we're ready for
sense too so we are very geared up and
if they they are they are really the
number one state of terror in the world
now I have to say they pull back because
they their money is running very low the
deal the president Obama made was a
disaster because it was such a short
term it didn't cover ballistic missiles
and they couldn't see the important
sites under this you couldn't inspect
the important sites there are many
things wrong and of course they gave a
hundred and fifty billion dollars plus
1.8 billion in green green beautiful
cash that's called many plane loads of
here I think Pakistan would like to have
some of those things but they gave one
point eight billion dollars in cash
which is unthinkable and instead of
being respectful and thankful which
brightly they should have been to the
United States and to President Obama for
making that ridiculous deal instead of
being respectful they put their finger
up in the air and this thing is a dollar
they put their finger up in the air and
they disrespected the United States you
shouldn't have done that that was a big
mistake one of the best things I've done
is terminate that ridiculous here if
they want to make a deal it's it's
frankly it's getting harder for me to
want to make a deal with Iran because
they behaved very badly they're saying
bad things and I'll tell you it could go
either way very easily very easily and
I'm okay either way it goes
give me what they didn't do in the world
why don't think back to Stan I don't
think back to Stan respected the United
States
I don't think Pakistan respected its
presidents and I think Pakistan could
have done a lot I think Pakistan came to
a tremendous amount against with respect
to Afghanistan they didn't do it and I
don't blame them because they were
dealing with the wrong president who
knows but I think Pakistan could have
done they're helping us a lot now I
think they could have helped us a lot in
the past but it doesn't matter we have a
new leader he's going to be a great
leader of Pakistan and we have a new
leader here sort of new two and a half
years now getting to be three years can
you believe it you're gonna find time
flies but no I think Pakistan could have
done a lot but they chose not to that's
because they did not respect us
leadership well I'll let you know that
very quickly I'll let you know I mean
I'm gonna know soon it's not gonna be
like a long term thing I I figured
things out very quickly so the question
was that's probably the best question
you've asked it Muller Muller a mother
she's been asking this the best question
I have to focus on that because that's
such a great question I think Pakistan
is going to do a lot I really do
I think Pakistan is going to make a big
difference I think Pakistan will save
millions of lives in Afghanistan because
I really believe they can they have a
power that other nations don't have with
respect to Afghanistan and I will say as
of this moment they're working very hard
and very nicely
[Music]
by gangs and potentially sort of looking
the other way allowing these peaceful
protesters have you've seen and many of
that footage and even briefed on anybody
I have a patient
you know I know president
you
I know that they're working I know
that's a very important situation for
President Xi and you could say what you
said but you could also say that he has
allowed that to go on for a long time
and you know it's been it's been
relatively I think it's been relatively
nonviolent
I don't think China has stopped him the
China could stop them if they want and I
think I think that again I'm not
involved in it very much but I think
President Xi of China has acted
responsibly very responsibly they've
been out there protesting for a long
time I've never seen protests like it
where you have that many people it looks
like 2 million people there's a big
birthday but I think the president I
hope that President Xi will do the right
thing but it has been going on a long
time there's no question mr. president
good remarks about Pakistan and said
that Iran can help not to end the
violence in Afghanistan the dialogue
process and reconciliation process so
what really Pakistan can do to bring
peace because we are also complained by
your deputy commander general about you
and other security team so what solution
Pakistan what strategy paper you have to
push forward the peace and
reconciliation process in Afghanistan
and assurances to the u.s. yes what
number one this is the longest war that
the United States has ever fought
it's almost because anyone who knows the
history of Afghanistan you just have to
look back at the history
there was always going to be a political
settlement at the end and I have to
compliment President Trump because he
has to end the war you have a have a
settlement and that's where I think
Pakistan is playing a very important
role because Pakistan has a 1,500 mile
border with you and my talks with
President we have a military leadership
here because this is obviously a
security situation and what we want is
Understanding between the two countries
I can show President Trump that whatever
we will be saying will be the app we
will be straight with them they will
rope and never be any question of any
doubt on Pakistan's intent because in a
part from Afghanistan the country that
wants peace and of honest and more than
any other countries Pakistan it will
bring a directly affected by it and
Pakistan needs stability we have had 15
years of fighting this war on terror
over 70,000 Pakistani casualties over a
hundred and fifty billion dollars lost
to the economy so we desperately want
peace and I'm happy that President Trump
has pushed it forward
[Music]
[Music]
it's the most powerful country in the
world the United States it can play the
most important role and bring it peace
in the subcontinent you know there are
over and a quarter people in the
subcontinent they are held hostage to
the issue of fresh meat and I feel that
only the most powerful state headed by
President Trump and can bring the two
countries together I my point I can tell
you we have tried our best
we made all illusions to India to to
start dialogue resolve our differences
through through dialogue but
unfortunately we haven't made headway as
yet but I'm hoping the president shop
would know I was with I was with Prime
Minister Modi two weeks ago we talked
about this subject and he actually said
would you like to be a mediator or
arbitrator as I said we're so casual
because this been going on for many many
years I was surprised at how long I've
been going on 70 years I think they'd
like to see it resolved and I think
you'd like to see result that if I can
help I would love to be a mediator it
should be I mean it's impossible to move
to incredible countries that are very
very smart with very smart leadership
can't solve a problem like that but if
you would want me to mediate or
arbitrate I would be willing to do
the prayers of over a billion people if
you can media to resolve the decision
ship your results oh but he asked me the
same thing so I think there's something
so maybe we'll speak to him or I'll
speak to them and we'll see if we can do
so because I've heard so much about
Kashmir yeah it's such a beautiful name
supposed to be such a beautiful part of
the world but right now there's just
bombs all over the place they say
everywhere you go you have bombs and
it's a it's a terrible situation been
going on for many years if I can do
anything to help that let me know let me
give you one thing on Afghanistan as an
example so a lot of you don't know this
but we dropped the largest non-nuclear
bomb ever built in history we dropped it
in Afghanistan we were getting ready to
make many of those bombs this left a
hole that was it took out a lot of big a
lot of the tunnels in the world but it
left a hole in the earth that look like
the moon it looked like a crater from
the moon still there it was nobody's
ever seen anything like it
people heard it 15 miles away they said
what was that it shook the earth
non-nuclear
you
see solutions that's actually the easy
solution and they'd come in and say
let's have peace but you don't have to
do that I think we're going to be very
successful without having to go that
route and I have tremendous confidence
in the Prime Minister one or two more
[Music]
has one of the freest presses of the
world all you have to do is since I've
been the prime minister in the last 10
months
I mean the criticism I have received
from my own breasts unprecedented right
so Sid herbs on Pakistan presses is a
joke wait a minute wait wait you see for
no way you're treated worse tonight
gonna have to speak because I didn't
hear your words freedom of the press we
will do that we will - we're talking
about hostages we're talking about
hostages being held in various places
I've had very good luck with ostriches
with North Korea with many places
they've treated us with respect and I
appreciate it made a big difference we
have two or three hostages that we're
talking about that's one of the
gentlemen that we have heard about and
will be we will be discussing that with
many other subjects yes
I think they're very bad for our country
I really think they must hate our
country I think therefore congressman
we're talking about the Congress women
what they've said about Israel what
they've said about our country when they
talk about disgusting people when they
talk the way they talk when the one
mentioned that brown people should speak
for brown people and Muslim people
should speak for Muslim people and you
hear all this it's not what our country
is all about no I think they're very bad
for our country I think they're very bad
for the Democrat Party I think you see
that and they're pulling the Democrats
way left nobody knows how to handle them
I feel they're easy to handle to me
they're easy to handle because they're
just out there they're very bad for our
country absolutely there's no racial
tension but mr. burr I had my best
numbers recently and it's because of the
economy of what I've done feel of the
afternoon America when you look at the
African Americans are doing better than
they've ever done in our country that
we're creating numbers look at the
poverty numbers look at so many
different look at the unemployment
numbers the best they've ever had now we
have fantastic relationships with the
African American community I think
you'll see that certainly you're going
to see that in 2020
that you are gonna win the 20/20
lectures and you are obviously pretty
cautious about that same thing of
ibrahim sir you are also having a big
war against corruption in pakistan sir
can you just I think he's gonna win and
I think what's gonna happen I agree and
I think that's very true and it's
actually a very good question the answer
is yes I see great trade with Pakistan
and I'm not talking about a little bit
more I'm talking about we could go 10
and even 20 times what we're doing right
now
Pakistan is a big country it's actually
a very big country and they have
tremendous product they make great
products they make tremendous I bought
from Pakistan over the years when I was
in the private sector they make
incredible product
they're brilliant people they are
hardworking people I think we're gonna
have a fantastic trade relationship I
don't mean we'll increase it by 20% I
mean I think we can quadruple it I think
if you go I mean literally sounds great
you can go 10 times more you could go 20
times better because what we do right
now is that much and we should do a lot
so I think that's gonna be and I also do
agree that that has so much to do with
great peace having a great trading
relationship has so much to do with
peace and extremism in this case I think
it can happen so I expect that we were
within a very short period of time start
having very significant trade with back
we just have a very good relationship
then probably they would like to meet
and we'll see what happens there was a
little car spawn dance recently we're
very positive correspondence with North
Korea again there's new nuclear testing
there's no missile testing there's
nothing when they're ready when they're
ready we'll be we'll be discussing mr.
prime minister but I think I can very
well have a very good relationship with
Prime Minister Modi and I think we're
gonna have a phenomenal relationship
with the Prime Minister of Pakistan
I do think that it's a two-way street
you know you say India's coming in and
destabilizing Pakistan India is saying
that Pakistan is coming in and
destabilizing so there's a lot of room
right there where we can meet I think we
yeah the question I'll put one person
did he step down he's a terrible
governor I think you have an even worse
mayor of San Juan she's horrible I think
she's horrible I watched her my people
did nothing but complain about her when
we helped them with their hurricane
problem the mayor of San Juan Puerto
Rico is a horror show she's incompetent
grossly
confident at the same time the
governor's not good
so the United States Congress you won't
believe that please close your ears
because this would be gave Puerto Rico
ninety two billion dollars last year for
hurricane relief now they haven't got
the money all of it but they've got a
lot of it but they're scheduled together
the Congress of the United States handed
him ninety two billion dollars and that
ninety two billion dollars is in the
hands of incompetent people and very
corrupt people but the governor has done
a terrible job and the mayor of San Juan
has she's horrible I think she's just
terrible she's so bad for her people and
I think the government of the United
States have to be careful I'm the best
thing that ever happened to Puerto Rico
because we did a great job in Puerto
Rico they don't like to give me the
credit for it but we did a great job at
many Puerto Rican friends I have a real
understanding of Puerto Rico I've had
jobs in Puerto Rico I had I think the
most successful I owned the Miss
Universe contest of pageants and we had
them in Puerto Rico twice and I'll tell
we had tremendous successes in fact they
said literally a hundred percent this
never happens almost I think so a
hundred a hundred percent of the island
itself was watching they liked those
pageants I've had a great relationship
with Puerto Rico I'm the best thing that
ever happened to Puerto Rico but
Congress has given them 92 billion
dollars Pakistan without some of it
thank you
not 1.3 because Pakistan was getting 1.3
92 billion dollars and the money is
squandered and wasted and stolen and
I'll tell you what the Senators are not
happy about it and Congress is not happy
about it because you really do you have
incompetent totally grossly incompetent
leadership at the top of Puerto Rico the
people of Puerto Rico are great and the
people of Puerto Rico like me and they
should because nobody's given them what
I give them
but the leadership is corrupt and
incompetent thank you very much
[Music]
that was okay but the one before breasts
let's go keep moving